you need to focus your or all your
energy and and and
to build it and you need to raise
capital as quickly as possible
you need to hire uh the best employees
as quickly as possible
you need to build a product as quickly
as possible you need to start working
with the market with customers right
from the start
you don't need to build something for 24
months in your garage
and then go to the market and find out
that it's not the right solution
you need to work with the market right
from the start and it's all about growth
it's all about running as quickly as you
can
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
it is weird that i get to speak to
somebody who has so much experience in
the cyber world over 20 years of
experience as a serial entrepreneur as
an investor and executive
meet shai morag the ceo of our medic
previously he co-founded and was ceo of
sekdo a cyber security company that was
acquired by palo alto networks and of
integrity project
a company specialized in connectivity
networking and security solutions
acquired by mellanox
shai served for 10 years as an officer
in the idf intelligence core
unit 8200 where he held a variety of
roles in management and product
development and won several national
awards for excellence
shai is a graduate of the talpiyot
program and earned an mba from tel aviv
university
shai morag welcome to my show how are
you
very good how are you thank you for
having me i am extremely excited to have
you
we're going to have a lot of fun talking
both about your journey but also cyber
in general in the cyber security space
a very hot space obviously and
both in terms of capital in terms of
talent in terms of our own ecosystem
here in israel
and you're really an integral part of
this ecosystem with some incredible
adventures that that you've been a part
of and and i'm excited to
to touch both on you know segdo but also
on
on automatic and understand a little bit
better
your insights into the industry but
before all that i have to talk a little
bit about poker because it's a it's a
personal passion of mine
and i'm always excited when i meet
somebody so smart who all
who also really enjoys the game tell me
a little bit about your
your experience with poker and with
bridge as well
okay cool uh so it's uh i would say it's
great questions and i would say that uh
also
probably there is also some similarity
uh between poker and bridge and also i
would say on being an
entrepreneur and and founding companies
so
uh just maybe to share with uh with
everyone that i play poker i play bridge
uh both i would say it's not my
profession but it's like i would say
it's semi-professional it's just it's
it's more than a hobby and i would say
there is a lot of similarity between the
games
both of the games are games of i would
say missing or
not enough information you have some
information
uh limited information i would say you
have some information you have the
information of your cards
in some cases like in bridges in some
time or or something
during the game you have more
information from other cards or for
other player cards
but you need to infer what they have or
what's your decision
that is based on what they have what you
expect them to have what's the
probability or the chances for them to
have
in poker you need to infer it from the
way that they play
the way that they bat the way that they
react to your bat
the way from what they are doing
sometimes it's from physical reads
in some places but in many cases it's
just based on how they play
um and you need to understand what is
their their range or what
is the what's the possibility of all the
cards that they can have
also in bridge but pretty much the same
in both of the games
it's very even even in that in some
cases poker
seems to be like a game i would say
gambling or or
or gambling game in my mind it's mostly
a game of missing information unlimited
information
and this is pretty much the challenge
and i would say that also in in
building companies you on and you don't
have all the information you need to
have decision
decisions that are made on limited
information
you need to based on to build your
strategy based on limited information
and you need to be ready to lose in some
cases because you're wrong in some cases
and you win
in some cases and if you play correctly
and if you build your company correctly
you win more than you lose
uh and in the long term it makes sense
um i love i love the way you're looking
at this
you know i've been i've been feeling so
isolated in my viewpoint on poker that
you know in some cultures they look at
it as gambling i i always look at
daniel negrano and phil ivey and phil
hellmuth and the way that they you know
they play the people they don't play the
cards it's the decisions under
under uncertainty and what you're
describing here is sometimes you need to
lose in order to get the information
you know sometimes you're you're playing
to not even to to win the specific hand
because you understand
that the journey is more complicated
than one specific hand it's it's
understanding the players it's a
marathon
and then uh people shouldn't be
surprised when it's usually the same
nine people
arriving at the final table of the world
series of poker or at least
some combination or permutation of those
people and and i love the analogy
to to startups now a little bit about
you
so you're deep into the cyber world
with multiple ventures both as an
investor but also as an entrepreneur
you know i'd love to start sort of 30
000 feet in the air and then dive down
to what you're doing today
cyber for you what what is it really
about
so uh i would say probably many things
so first there is the real i would say
the real need in the market and the real
mission
to help the world and help improve the
world i would say
uh there is a real challenge with cyber
crime and
in general we are we are in the internet
we are all our data is out there
uh and and there is risks that or or
criminals or or sometimes even countries
or states that try
eventually to uh take the advantage of
the
data that is out there and and we want
to improve the world again i would say
this is
pretty much uh uh one of the main things
here
and and and the second thing it's it's
my profession i would say
it's what i know best i'm doing it for
around 25 years
i was trained to do it i understand the
ecosystem i understand the industry i
understand the technology
i started my career uh as a soldier i
would say i served in the telpeo
program and then in the a200 unit doing
cyber security since
pretty much the beginning of my careers
it's pretty much since being since my
early 20s um and
and i understand i understand what's
happening i understand the tech and
and building companies understand come
the companies that
on the ecosystem understand the needs
understand the market understand
the customers so i would say so first of
course it's something that i'm
passionate because
there is also uh some ideals here
and but it's also something that i do
best uh and i excel in
and this is something that of course i
we like as as
as human beings we we like to be to
excel in things and we like to do things
that we
we do well um so pretty much
these are the probably the main reasons
why i'm in this in this industry i would
say
and so 20 25 years in the industry
you've you're pretty much you know a
pioneer in
in the cyber security space we're seeing
it growing complexity in exponential
in exponential capacities uh really you
know remarkably i'm saying
every two or three years i'm seeing a
breadth of of new types of companies
emerge for new types of problems that
even when i was you know in the 8200
unit i didn't even
consider existed and and and it's you
know both inspiring in some capacity but
it's also a little bit
scary and and challenging to keep up how
you know how has cyber security
transformed
across these 20 years in your eyes has
it become much more complex
what has been the main challenge of of
keeping up and making sure you're always
on top
so it's uh it's also a great question i
would say so
we know that because i would say pretty
much because of the damage from cyber
is estimated somewhere i would say
pretty much maybe in around a trillion
dollars a year and maybe it's an
underestimation
there is a real need in the market and
of course the industry will grow
and this is why you see more and more
startups you see more and more and more
companies that try to solve
uh some of the problems or many of the
problems
but i do believe that there we see even
though that we see
more problems and more companies i do
believe that
as an industry we are moving forward
we're not moving backward
backwards i would say that we are
focusing
in some cases some of the things that
took us
many many many years to develop in the
beginning of this
this i would say the cyber the cyber or
the cyber world
right now we do it quickly it's uh many
of the things that
the improvement with with cloud the
improvement with
how you develop new software so i would
say many of the things
we can develop solutions a lot quicker
we can and and also this is something
that we see also in the industry many of
the solutions
work and integrate and work together
which is also very important so i would
say as an industry
we're evolving so i feel that we're
moving forward
even though that there are still new
technologies all the time a new
infrastructure that you need to protect
so there is also uh
new needs and and the needs are also
evolving so
i expect the industry to continue to
grow because there is a real need
but i do feel that we're moving forward
um so there is hope i would say
not i would not look at it as something
pessimistic
right and obviously you know as
technology progresses and we've seen
this
tremendous acceleration over this past
year you know in terms of digitalization
of a lot of
infrastructure that previously was on
premise and all of a sudden now we're
seeing this cat and mouse game
between you know the attackers and the
defenders the red and blue teams just
becoming more and more frequent and more
and more industries
and so a lot of the times when i hear a
lot of people say that you know the
cyber security space is a bubble and
it's
and it's not justified it you know it it
stings a little bit because in my mind
that that statement just doesn't make
sense i mean we're seeing an industry
that is
very soon going to be dominating you
know in the tech world
at least as far as i can see it right
right
right so i completely i completely agree
i would say the
the need again this is why i don't think
that there is a bubble here
the need for cyber security solutions is
only growing and why is that i would say
everything is digitized we know the
digital transformation also because of
the covet 19 also
like we lived like i don't know five
years ahead of time
everything everyone are are doing the
digital transformation even
even before day planned before i would
say um
and the need is really really there this
is one
on the i would say another another uh
thing which is very very very important
here
to understand that because all the data
is out there there are new compliance
and regulation all the time and the
liability on the companies
and on the executives and the leadership
of the companies
is also something that we see more and
more in the last
few years we know that the gdpr
eventually created a big very big
liability
on the companies to make sure that they
protect the data of their customers
and also there is also liability
personal liability to leadership
and and and executives in the companies
and gdpr was just the the first i would
say the first regulation that created
this but you have
this privacy regulation that everyone
knows and talks you have the ccpa you
have other
privacy regulations that eventually
creates more and more and more
responsibility and liability on
companies to make sure that they protect
their uh customers
data and they protect the customer's
privacy uh
so i would say that the need is out
there the need is
only growing because you have more you
have more data you have more
digital data i would say and you have
more
uh requirements and more liability and
more uh
compliance and regulation and it makes
everything is make sense here so i would
say
the need is growing and when you look at
israel again and specifically for if you
look at
our local industry we have
the talents here are amazing if you
compare it to the rest of the award
for many reasons again we cannot i'm not
trying to we're not trying to be
uh i would say a show off here or too
proud here but
we should be proud because we have the
tenants here because we're working on it
uh in in the army we're working on it in
the intelligence corps we understand
that it's a it's a main challenge
um the government decided to invest in
this space because
they also understood so i would say that
then the main reason that you also
yeah exactly so i would say that the
main
main main reason that we see also many
companies coming
coming out from israel it's not a bubble
it's because there is really need
real unreal talent here and so
now the question that has to be asked
cyber security expert
20 25 years in the industry you've seen
you've seen a lot you've gone through a
lot you've invested in a lot
you decide to to found a company
aromatic and
even you know before what our medic does
what how do you go through a process of
identifying yourself
you know i see this industry i
understand a lot of it
i know the talent i know what's
happening i know what the big challenges
are how do you decide what challenge
you want to solve because you can't
solve all of them you're going to choose
you know a problem and you're going to
tackle it really really well
how do you even go about choosing which
problem to solve
yeah it's it's uh it's an excellent
question i would say in every
entrepreneur and everyone that wants to
found
wants to to have to found a a company i
would say
uh needs to ask himself uh what is the
way or what is the the secret sauce here
so i can share what we did uh all
of us the four founders of firmatic all
of us are repeat entrepreneurs all of us
understand the market all of us
understand the ecosystem and and
and we've done it before so the what
what we decided to do
is again um i would say is ask the
market
where are their needs and go talk with
the market we understand that the
knowledge
and even though that we are experienced
and we know eventually the customers and
the market
really understand what it needs so what
we did we did a couple of things
first we interviewed more than 50
customers specifically the csos
for cyber security because they are the
the buyer they are the economical biodel
in some cases also the user but they
understand what they need and we also
ran a survey with 300 systems we used
idc
we worked with idc uh to have a survey
with 300 cisos
and ask them what keeps them up at night
what are their top concerns
and we decided to focus on the challenge
where we're focusing to the enermetic on
cloud security and specifically on cloud
security on
infrastructure security and specifically
on around identity and access because we
found out
that this is the things that keep them
up at night these are their top concerns
and so you identify a you identify that
specific segment
for repeat entrepreneurs and and how do
and then what happens so you start and
you say now what
so you have the you know you have the
data you have the passion you have the
experience
how do you then grow so quickly so it's
it's a great question so first of course
you need to make sure that even even the
though that the market tells you what it
needs you need to
to understand and to research and to
understand that there is uh a demand
here but
not enough supply you need to understand
that this is a growing market or growing
enough market
uh that there is an opportunity here to
build the company
and after you're doing all the research
research is the key here
it's not something that you need to
decide without the research you need to
research you need to understand
what is the demand again we discuss it
with the market what is the supply what
are the competition
what are the competitors what the
competitors are doing and what other
other companies
have in this space and this is even if
it's also part of the trend
and then you execute you focus your
whole life on that of course
yeah i have kids i have a wife i need to
make sure that i also
probably i'm a father this is the first
thing uh that uh probably uh
uh characterized me but again you need
to focus your or
all your energy and and and to build it
and you need to raise
capital as quickly as possible you need
to hire
the best employees as quickly as
possible you need to build a product as
quickly as possible you need
to start working with the market with
customers right from the start
you don't need to build something for 24
months in your garage
and then go to the market and find out
that it's not the right solution
you need to work with the market right
from the start and it's all about growth
it's all about
running as quickly as you can i would
say you start as you start very quickly
and then you you increase your speed as
probably we know the the quote from uh
from the famous movie
um you take on an additional challenge
because you're not just the founder
you're also the ceo and you know with
that comes a lot of responsibility
to not only say yes we have a great
problem we have a great team we have
capital
we bring on a few dozen amazing people
to be on the team
now you have to continue maintaining a
culture of excellence
right you know in the space that you're
in if you
don't improve your you die you go
backwards you can't just
provide the same solution for forever
and
and assume that the world stays the same
because everything around you
not just competitors but also the red
team you know things advance
things change how do you as the ceo now
think through building this culture of
excellence if you will
it's it's a it's a great question so
another thing that we did in in the
beginning and this is also
i would say a big part of the
responsibility of the founders and the
ceo
is to make sure that we understand what
are the values
of our company what is the culture that
we want to create
um and when you start talking about it
you find out that even though that
probably all of the founders and all of
the ceos want
many things when you prioritize them you
found out that it's different between
probably it's different between
different companies different ceos
different founders um and this is
something that you really need to invest
uh and think about and really eventually
choose and build your company
based on the values based on the core
values uh
for us it was very important of course
to find smart people which is of course
very important but i would say that in
also very important for us was ownership
i don't know if for for other
ceos ownership is the most important
thing in terms of how they choose
or how they build their country uh
culture
we wanted to make sure that everyone
that works for the company has
an ownership of what he does and we
don't we don't want
people who are on we need to micromanage
again it will be a very challenge to
create a big company
um so you need eventually to decide and
and to maintain it
is is is uh is is challenging you need
to make sure that every decision that
you make you have your
core values and everything that you
talked about and
thought about you need to make sure that
it's it's it's
it's uh it's on the same page you need
to make sure that when you say that
ownership is most important when someone
eventually
doesn't perform well on this part you
want oh
sometimes you replace him i don't know
or you choose the right person based on
that and not on others
if you want to make sure that there is a
collaboration in your company you make
sure you need to make sure that
the compensation sometimes is also based
on collaboration so
you need to make sure that you put uh uh
put the dollars where your mouth is i
would say um so so also this is
something that
needs to needs to align uh and it's also
it's
also a very big part and i would say in
different stages of the company
it's very hard when you grow from the
founders to i don't know the first core
team it's it's it's a challenge but when
you grow to 50 people it's a challenge
then you need to grow to 100 people it's
a challenge and then you grow i don't
know a couple of hundreds or 500 he said
all of them are different challenges and
it's not the same uh
this is also very fascinating and being
the ceo and being the founder of a
company
and it sounds like one of the most
exciting pieces that you overcome
one challenge and oh you're confronted
by the next challenge because if you
succeeded in that challenge
you you get to be challenged again and
again
in the various stages and and it sounds
like it's it's extremely extremely
exciting and rewarding
uh shy i have to let you go back to run
a company but i do have a few
questions if you're open to them
all right cool yeah of course favorite
subject in
school middle school or high school
so probably again i was a geek in school
so i need to be if i'm
if i'm honest i'm being honest and i
would not say sports because it's not
it's not the real thing it's not it's
not the truth
that uh probably the main the thing that
i liked best was math
i was a math geek i did my my
bagrot exam earlier i i started my
bachelor degree in
high school again i was a geek in high
school i'm probably i'm a geek also
right now but
let's say i'm not i i can't say i'm
surprised by the answer
uh who is somebody that you that
inspires you somebody that you look up
to
a role model if you will
i would say that probably uh
the first first name that really again
i'm i'm admiring many people but i will
say the first name that comes to mind
probably when you're an entrepreneur
you're trying
to find who of the entrepreneurs or the
founders
you really look up to and i would say
elon musk is probably the one that
i'm sure others say it but again it's
someone that you really see
how he builds companies and you can
admire how he built
sometimes i don't like the culture that
he creates and i have some
some i i don't agree with everything
that he does
but you you really need to admire how we
build such great companies
so quickly uh it's unbelievable
and what are three words that if i were
to ask anybody
or some people who is shy morag who is
he
it's uh it's uh it's a terrific question
i would say
so so probably the first word again i'm
i'm trying to answer for others but
probably i'll try to
to do it myself uh so probably again if
i want to describe myself first i would
start even though that i'm an
entrepreneur and and and
and this is my profession and my passion
probably
uh further and i don't know it's it's
probably the the
i would say the first word that comes to
mind again
um this is a life-changing life-changing
event
i would say having kids it's one uh
probably the second thing is i would say
they described me as entrepreneur
i had the chance of doing something else
i had the chance of retiring after
selling a couple of companies
but i really i really want to continue i
think this is part of my passion and my
my
my driving life entrepreneurship yeah
that's entrepreneurship i would say so
probably
anyone that knows me will characterize
me as as such
and if i really need to think about the
third world which is not really a
description
but uh i would say pretty much
probably depth meaning i do believe and
again this is also part of being
entrepreneur i
i prefer focusing on one problem and one
issue and and
getting to dive deeper as possible to
this challenge
and not like even though that i'm also
an investor but it's not i would say
it's very hard for me to invest in many
many many companies
because i really it's very hard not to
dive uh
as deep as i want so probably this would
be the third
thing that would characterize me
probably shy
thank you very very much this was uh
insightful and great
i'll let you go back to running a
company but i really appreciate you
taking the time i look forward to
sharing this with others
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you verma thank you for having me
and it was a pleasure real pleasure